la parole aux centristes ce soir mme en
preuve par 3 dans le cadre des élections
municipales avec jean arthuis comme
invité bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sénateur de la mayenne ancien ministre
du budget est très certainement tête de
liste du centre européenne aux élections
européennes de mai prochain
c'est aussi président de l'alliance
centriste parti qui appartient à
l'alternative l'alternative que
l'alliance borloo bayod bref il faut s'y
retrouver un peu dans cette nébuleuse
centriste alors justement notre confrère
deborah claude delage en ce sens presse
partenaire de l'émission ainsi que
dailymotion nous aidera à y voir un
petit peu plus clair tout à l'heure elle
reviendra avec vous sur le projet des
centristes pour les élections
européennes notamment
et puis dans la dernière partie de cette
émission mickaël szames s de public
sénat vous demandera pourquoi quitter
une maison à priori confortable comme le
sénat pour le parlement européen qui est
en général moins prisé par les hommes
politiques français
alors l'europe justement jean arthuis
dans le cadre de la crise et craignent n
cette semaine elle peine à faire
entendre sa voix est-ce que vous
déplorez cette incapacité à se mettre
d'accord et ce manque de réactivité de
l'europe et c'est que l'europe politique
n'existe pas il n'y a pas de pilote
politique en europe
on l'a vu en maths circonstances
tempérament du pays chargé de la
présidence pour six mois de l'europe
peut parfois pallier cette vacuité
on n'a rien on l'a vu en 2008 avec la
crise en géorgie et l'attitude très
volontariste à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui les
situations la situation est pathétique
on voit bien que européens sont
incapables de définir une position
commune
les pays de l'est ont retrouvé leur
liberté lorsque à la suite de la chute
du mur de berlin
le rideau de fer a disparu et ces pays
s'efforce de faire vivre la démocratie
sur leur territoire mais on voit bien qu
en ukraine l'état est défaillant il y a
un déficit d'état
situation et et que financières terrible
puisque ce pays va être peut-être demain
en rupture de paiement et on voit
également sauvé les crèmes site en fait
je pense que l'europe n'a pas les moyens
le budget de l'union européenne ne le
permet pas ça ne peut être que par des
conventions entre les membres de l'union
européenne
phénomène qu'on a pu vérifier à
l'occasion de la crise des dettes
souveraines notamment en grèce mais
aujourd'hui l'europe n'a pas les moyens
il faut passer par le fonds monétaire
international
ce qu'il va falloir quand même c'est que
l'union européenne définisse clairement
sa position sa vision à fond sera peint
du continent européen et quel type de
relation
nous voulons entretenir avec la russie
voyez bien qu'il ya déjà hiatus en ce
moment entre les ex pays d'europe de
l'est la pologne notamment en tête et
puis nous pays d'europe de l'ouest faire
à cette crise ukraine l'élargissement
l'élargissement de l'europe a été trop
rapide les institutions européennes
n'ont pas été confortée fortifiée et on
voit bien que la gouvernance de l'union
européenne est largement défaillante il
ya des bus de gouvernance dans la zone
euro qui pourrait bien être l'embryon du
fédéralisme européen
mais s'agissant du marché unique les
positions sont souvent très
contradictoires on voit que c'est
peut-être par la voie économique que
l'europe à pouvoir exercer une pression
sur la russie est encore quelconque
quelles sanctions économiques
justement ce même sur ces sanctions
économiques je n'y a pas de plan pour
l'instant de l'union de l'été lorsque la
commission européenne soudainement a
voulu prendre des mesures contre les
importations de panneaux photovoltaïques
venant de chine impositions à 50% et
bien immédiatement le premier ministre
chinois est arrivé chez madame merkel
parce que le pouvoir en europe
on identifie assez facilement avec la
république fédérale d'allemagne et la
chancelière
encore cette semaine bladimir poutine
n'a comme les européens locutrice en
europe et les mercenaires et les
européens ont été incapables de
s'entendre par rapport à l'application
de cette taxe anti dumping pour venir
cette crise et craignait gratuit est ce
que vous regrettez un volontarisme comme
celui de nicolas sarkozy en 2008 lors de
la crise géorgienne
ou est-ce que angela merkel peut
incarner maintenant cette force
politique et dans le cas d'une crise
grave internationales en europe et le
volontarisme le oui mais au nom de qui
et avec quel consensus des européens
cela suppose que l'europe proclame
qu'elle entend cessé à l'heure de la
globalisation de la mondialisation qui
inquiète tant nos concitoyens que
l'europe entend assumer un rôle de
puissance mondiale
nous avons un poids économique qui place
en effet l'économie l'union européenne
au premier rang au plan mondial
mais cette europe là est un nain
politique un nain diplomatique et
françois hollande comment vous le
trouvez dans la gestion de cette crise
et ukrainienne je trouve très très
discret l'est peut-être mais peut-être
nom est une contradiction en demandant
pardon de la république à lui seul de
d'entraîner les européens ce que je
souhaite c'est que avec discrétion
il est en concertation permanent
permanente avec ses partenaires
européens pour tenter d'arrêter une
position commune essayons quand même de
jouer le collectif et de piles étaient
collectivement le destin de l'union
européenne on a vu qu'à l'occasion de la
crise au mali et puis en centrafrique la
france a réagi seule et quand elle s'est
retournée y avait personne derrière je
pense qu il serait essentiel qu avant
toute intervention militaire où que ce
soit il est européen se concertent et
essaie de définir une position commune
et de s'engage une hanche enverra sur
mary sion emballages arc seule condition
de la crédibilité
au risque qu'il ne se passe jamais rien
parce que je veux dire c'est que ses
prérogatives de souveraineté nationale
lorsqu'on les exercent au plan national
dans pratiquement toutes les situations
nous affichons une impuissance politique
nous faisons semblant mais n'ont
notamment pas les moyens à la hauteur de
nos ambitions et on voit bien que pour
retrouver cette souveraineté
il faut la partager il faut la gérer
ensemble au sein de l'union européenne
ce soir au sénat et à la présidente du
groupe front de gauche manama sassi qui
demande au premier ministre une
consultation du parlement français sur
la crise et craignant est ce que vous y
êtes favorable je pense qu'il est très
judicieux que le gouvernement fasse
connaître au parlement son analyse de la
situation et les positions qu'il entend
prendre en charge ce sujet selon le
quotidien le parisien jean arthuis le
gouvernement réfléchirait à une baisse
de 10 milliards d'euros des aides
accordées aux collectivités
territoriales vous vous êtes présent
d'un département la mayenne
alors vous allez compenser comment ce
manque financier est-ce que ce que
j'attends du gouvernement c'est de la
cohérence
c'est vrai que pour l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et communes
les communautés de communes les
communautés urbaines et départements les
régions
globalement les dépenses engagées sont
de l'ordre de 220 milliards par an et
pour en assurer le financement
l'état verse à peu près 100 milliards il
est clair qu'au moment où le président
proclament et il a raison qu'il faut
réduire d'au moins 50 milliards
nos dépenses publiques ou les niveaux
d'administration vont devoir en tirer
les conséquences mais ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est l'attitude du
gouvernement je préside un conseil
général une collectivité locale
le gouvernement vient de sortir trois
décrets revalorisant les rémunérations
de nos collaborateurs fonctionnaires
je vais devoir inscrire en année pleine
six cent mille euros de dépenses
supplémentaires quelle cohérence y at-il
entre l' annonce d'une volonté de
réduire la dépense publique et la
multiplication de textes arrêté d'une
manière presque confidentielle qui tout
augmente la dépense publique pourquoi le
gouvernement
at il a supprimé la journée de carence
que tu es un début d'économies dans la
dépense publique
cette contradiction là n'est pas
supportable mais vous pensez que du coup
pour compenser ces 10 milliards d'euros
qui êtes supprimant collectivités
territoriales et bien ça va ça va passer
par une hausse des impôts locaux
ce serait totalement contradictoire les
français subissent et experts crime
subissent la hausse des impôts et un
ras-le-bol fiscale j'ai vécu ça par
exemple avec les droits de mutations sur
les transactions à titre onéreux dans
les dna théo qui vient d'augmenter
c'était plafonné à 3 8% le gouvernement
a dit pas écouter ce que vous pouvez
faire et c'est il est passé à 4 5% les
départements peuvent passer 3 8 à 4 5
mois en mayenne avec mes collègues
conseillers généraux nous avons refusé
cette augmentation parce qu'elle est en
contradiction avec cette volonté
affichée de réduire le montant des
prélèvements obligatoires et de réduire
la dépense publique
on a évoqué tout à l'heure l'allègement
des charges pour les entreprises est ce
que vous êtes de ceux qui pensent
actuellement que le pacte de
responsabilité un peu de plomb dans l
aile qui met trop de temps à décoller
gens j'attends les actes mois depuis des
années vous le savez bien vous avez
souvent entendu sur ce plateau vous dire
à quel point il est nécessaire de
redonner de la compétitivité aux
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
investir et créer des emplois qu'elles
puissent innover et aller de l'avant
or les marges des entreprises n'ont
jamais été aussi faibles
les charges sociales qui pèsent sur les
salaires sont les plus élevés d'europe
peut pas continuer ainsi
et cette façon de faire transiter
l'impôt par l'entreprise organisa s'est
méthodiquement les délocalisations
d'activités et l'explosion du chômage
donc les responsabilités sur la table à
une pédagogie à accomplir devant les
français pour cesser de dire que si on
baisse les charges sociales ce sont des
cadeaux faits aux entreprises
ce discours là est totalement périmés ce
que nous voulons c'est redonner
gouvernement 20 ans actuellement
oui il a le discours attendent à
entendre la pédagogie très déficiente et
les actes je ne suis pas sûr que le
président de la république
et une majorité pour voter les textes
qu'ils préparent le public n'a pas été
aidé non plus pierre gattaz un jour
qu'ils souhaitaient des contreparties le
lendemain qu'ils n'en voulaient plus qui
a affiché pendant longtemps son pin 1
millions d'emplois il a un peu aussi
tiré une balle en ce qu'il faut c'est un
gars tassement rétablir rétablir la
confiance et laisser ceux qui ont envie
d'entreprendre pouvoir le faire
aujourd'hui celui qui entreprend
immédiatement doit répondre à de
multiples formalités et il reçoit
instantanément des avis d'imposition de
cotisation que social que sais-je encore
le gouvernement a créé le cic eux qui
sont dit il sans le dire et est un début
de tva sociale mais ceci n'est possible
parce qu on a augmenté la tva pour
financer ce cic ce crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi alors on applique
aux salaires mais pour les travailleurs
indépendants les artisans les
commerçants les professions libérales
les agriculteurs ils subissent une
augmentation de tva mais non aucune
aucun allègement de leurs cotisations
sociales ce qui n'est pas juste
bernadette chirac et françois sauvadet
qui est vice-président de bd y présenter
aujourd'hui le livre noir du redécoupage
des cantons
ils dénoncent tous les deux un trip à
tour un tripatouillage électoral de la
part du gouvernement
mais jean arthur ne peut pas dire
indéfiniment qu'il ya trop de communes
autres collectivités de compte on en
français et qu'il faut rationaliser
cette organisation et crie au loup dès
qu'il ya une volonté d'un gouvernement
de simplification c'est pas vraiment
simplification moi dans mon département
de la mayenne c'est vrai que le
découpage et est assez étonnant ubuesque
puisque alfred jarry et et lavallois
mayenne est mais nous sommes 32
conseillers généraux aujourd'hui il y en
aura 34 demain donc le compte n'y est
pas ce que je trouve stupéfiant c'est
que on est d'abord statuer sur le mode
d'élection des conseillers généraux sans
prendre le temps
dans le cadre de la recherche
d'économies de la redéfinition des
compétences entre les régions
on les départements et les communes on
aurait dû commencer par préciser les
compétences des départements avant que
de définir le mode d'élection et les
contours des cantons on a créé des
cantayres on arriverait nombre des
cantons pour respecter la parité et donc
on aurait scrutin sans précédent assez
baroque
on élira un tandem une dame est un
monsieur qui se présenteront sur le même
sont les mêmes bulletins de vote
par contre la parité bien sûr mais je
pense qu'on peut arriver à la parité par
d'autres moyens
lorsque les femmes du tripatouillage
électoral ce que vous dénoncez
ah oui ça je pense qu'il ya dans mon
département par exemple s'il constate
que c'est sur laval le chef-lieu dans
les municipalités et socialiste les
cantons de laval vont être les cantons
les moins peuplées du département hier
ont stigmatisé la sur-représentation des
cantons ruraux
aujourd'hui il faut constater la
sur-représentation des cantons urbains
difficultés et se prêtent un procès en
suspicion de tripatouillage électoral
mais qui touche en général chacun des
gouvernements
dès qu'on veut toucher à la carte
électorale peut dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on a modifié les carnets électorale
le gouvernement s'est exposée au même
procès elle est on va parler du centre
maintenant genre tu es avec des barres à
claude de la sp qui va nous rejoindre
jean arthuis gelées du tout à l'heure
vous serez sans doute tête de liste du
centre pour les élections européennes de
mai prochain
alors les négociations ont été longues
entre lui dit et le modem et votre parti
aussi l'alliance centriste pour savoir
combien de têtes de liste par formation
il va y avoir il ya une volonté
d'alliance au centre mais ça ne s'est
pas fait sans douleur
on va regarder ce reportage jérôme
bonnard qui nous raconte les coulisses
de cette négociation
il aura fallu des semaines de
négociations tendues pour se partager
les cèpes tête de liste européenne
l'absence de jean louis borloo toujours
convalescent françois bayrou lui bien
occupé à pau par les municipales non
un ranger au final c'est tout de même le
modem avec marielle de sarnez qui
conduira la liste d'île de france
l'union des centristes est indispensable
l'europe c'est leur espoir de faire un
score à deux chiffres
alors du côté udi avec trois têtes de
listes acquise on préfère s'afficher
unie sur le fond il n'y a absolument
aucun problème
après il ya toujours des problèmes
d'hommes ou de femmes d'ailleurs ça ce
sont d'autres sujets mais sur la
question du projet on est on est
totalement courir jouer mis à part
peut-être un petit détail dans la
coordination
chantal jouanno apprenez seulement hier
par voie de presse avec qui elle va
coordonner la rédaction du projet des
européens
effectivement je ne savais pas qui
serait mon alter ego du côté du modem ne
savais pas que c'était robert rochefort
qui est une très bonne chose que je le
connais bien on se connaît de longue
date
reste que l'essentiel a pris du retard
le projet justement il sera dévoilée le
mois prochain
alors en attendant le tandem vient de
lancer une initiative citoyenne
européenne
l'objectif faire élire un président de
l'europe au suffrage universel aux
problèmes d'europe c'est quoi c'est que
aujourd'hui elle arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord pour avoir une stratégie
économique offensive
l'europe c'est une puissance sauf que
comme c'est un nain politique elle
n'arrive absolument pas en tirer des
bénéfices donc si on veut que l'europe
existe ici on veut qu'elles deviennent
une vraie puissance
il lui faut un président suffrage
universel direct ou par voie
parlementaire cela reste bien sûr à
définir mais pour certains faire grandir
l'europe dans sa totalité de cette façon
est utopique mais c'est une parfaite
higashi l'europe ce n'est pas la france
ce n'est pas un peuple européen qui
acceptent n'importe qui c'est un
ensemble de peuples et il faut veiller à
ce que tout le monde soit plus ou moins
directement associés il aurait mieux
valu se concentrer sur ce qui unit c'est
en profondeur les deux familles
centristes c'est à dire une option
européenne forte
c'est certainement ce qu'on attend le
plus des fédéralistes de l'alternative
d'ici le 25 mai prochain selon les
sondages ils peuvent s'attendre à 10
voire 15 % des suffrages
deborah club de l' agence france presse
afp est avec nous bonsoir de vaud ramon
soir mais 28 voilà vos questions à jean
arthuis sur le centre un très bien on va
commencer par les européennes puisque
c'était le sujet du reportage on les
attend depuis plusieurs semaines alors
où en est on l'accouchement est
difficile les listes européennes qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire autant
sur les têtes de listes où il va porter
dans chaque région en cette année
d'élections en préparation a été longue
mais ce qui me paraît très important
c'est précisément le rapprochement des
familles du centre et qui depuis 1998
s'était séparé et parfois chamailler la
voie du centre n'était plus audible
ce qui s'accomplit aujourd'hui les mêmes
que celles ci prennent un petit peu de
temps c'est ainsi que c'est compliqué
c'est plutôt non mais c'est plutôt bon
signe c'est plutôt bon signe ça veut
dire que avec l'imprimé et on a entendu
des éclats de voix des ego bon certains
l'idée ne voulait pas de marielle de
sarnez santé de santé démocratique
donc nous avons eu de très nombreuses
réunions c'est vrai trop nombreuses et
cet exercice là est un exercice
absolument indispensable il faut mettre
en commun une réflexion faire la part de
ce qui est essentiel
naturellement moment pour choisir les
le casting michael eisner au moins aussi
important que le casting
quelle vision quel projet pour l'europe
on n'y va pas seulement pour occuper des
postes au parlement européen
si on y va c'est parce qu'on a quelques
convictions c'est parce que on pense que
c'est grâce à l'europe qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver un niveau de croissance
satisfaisant suffisant pour créer des
emplois pour permettre aux jeunes
d'avoir des perspectives et mettre un
terme à cette tentation d'exil parce que
ils ne savent pas comment ils vont s'en
sortir ici en france et dans nombre de
pays européens mais aussi étroit c'est
important pour le sont parce que
l'alternative là aussi l'ambition de
faire face au front national avec des
têtes d'affiché très importante marine
le pen son père finit peau vous avez une
grande ambition sur ces élections donc
c'est effectivement important si le
casting est sûr c'est que il n'ya pas il
n'y avait pas une feuille de papier à
cigarette entre les positions de l'ue
dit et des composantes de lui dis qui je
l'espère à jour vont finir par par
fusionner pour faire un seul parti je
serai un désir profond
absolument moi j'ai créé une petite
formation qui s'appelle l'alliance
centriste parce que je ne savais plus où
mettre entre ceux qui étaient partis à
l'ump
à terme il en est pas encore là
monsieur la lune et y doit à lui dit
pour l'instant
enfin entre le 10 et le modem il n'y
avait pas une feuille de papier à
cigarette
s'agissant de l'engagement européen est
précisément au moment où les les
eurosceptiques vous dire et peut-être
même les europhobes vont donner la voix
comme jamais parce que c'est tellement
commode et de prendre l'europe comme
bouc émissaire de nos difficultés
mais l'europe est ce qu'elle est et les
dans cette situation de
dysfonctionnement de trop grande
distance par rapport à nos concitoyens
pourquoi parce que nos chefs d'état et
de gouvernement ont fait croire que tout
allait bien grâce à l'europe
et chacun a continué dans cette petite
turpitudes de gouvernance nationale au
risque d'afficher localement l'image
d'une impuissance qui exaspère nos
concitoyens et qu'il est désenchante
complètement par rapport à la politique
les seuls à croire à l'europe c'est ce
que ce que ces messages bien c'est la
raison c'est la raison pour laquelle on
sait toujours pas quand est-ce qu'il
faut qu'elles vont arriver ça ne va pas
tarder à cette heure tardive ou même
vous allez être tête de 10 ans je suis
je suis le répète vous êtes je suis
candidat à la candidature
je le confirme sans trouver rénégocier
le concurrencer dans les jours qui
viennent que j'espère ils ont même
viendra la confirmation officielle
j'espère que les projets en tout cas du
centre pour ces européennes
quant au projet canton projet c'est de
faire de l'europe une puissance que
l'europe nous permettent
pendant trop longtemps nous appuyer on
sent bien qu'il ya un euroscepticisme de
plus en plus fort les internautes y par
exemple ya ceux qui devraient sortir de
l'euro bon pourquoi on a fait l'euro
on a fait l'euro parce que pour le
savoir on n'avait pas été capable de
faire une politique vous sauver qu'en
1954 le parlement français avait rejeté
le projet le traité instituant une
communauté européenne de défense est
donc la voie politique était fermé
on a opté pour la voie économique avec
six pays le marché commun le marché
commun aulas élargi on l'a approfondie
beaucoup lorsque le mur de berlin est
tombé trop bas tarifs 4 ont élargi
les valeurs sûres mais maintenant ça y
est c'est fait et on s'est bien vite
rendu compte que lorsqu'il y à autant de
monnaie que deux pays constituant ce
marché unique
l'instabilité monétaire les variations
de parités monétaires introduisent des
dévaluations compétitives qui casse la
croissance et multiplie le nombre des
chômeurs dont vous croyez encore à
l'europe là ont récemment michel rocard
faisait une interview dans laquelle il
disait l'europe sert plus à rien a pas
harmoniser les normes
vous vous pensez qu'elle est perfectible
mais vous avez vous mettez encore
beaucoup d'espoir dans ce non non ces
institutions sans je pense qu'il n'y a
pas d'alternative à l'alternative qu'il
faut aller jusqu'au bout le jour on a
créé la mode est unique on a mis un pied
on a pris un billet d'alléchants retour
vers l'intégration politique
mais on en n'a pas tiré les conséquences
on a continué à faire subtiliser
affaires nationales
parce que le roux avait anesthésiée tout
le monde y compris les marchés
financiers et les agences de notation et
donc ça allait bien on ne respecte pas
on ne respectait pas les engagements la
france sa première on laissait aller le
déficit on a admis la grèce qui était
une stupidité intégrer la grèce dans la
zone euro compte tenu de sa situation ça
n'avait pas de sens l'ayant ta devise
on aurait dû la surveiller comment
surveille de lait sur le feu
naturellement ce qu'on s'est bien gardé
de faire mais ça marchait comme ça parce
que tout le monde croyait que la zone
euro était un espace fédéral il a fallu
attendre la crise de la grèce pour
réagir enfin et là je crois que ça y est
maintenant tout le monde a compris qu'il
faut une intégration politique de la
zone euro un gouvernement économique et
financier qui peut croire que l'on
pourrait réguler la finance
internationale un échelon infra
européens l'idée de créer une union
bancaire pour essayer de mettre une
séparation entre le risque systémique
des banques et l'engagement des états
est quand même une avancée
extraordinaire il porter cette parole au
mois de mai très forte vous espérez
entre 10 et 15% des suffrages la com
plus haut niveau possible jour pas si
vous êtes un souffle ouais c'est qu'en
tant donné la probabilité me paraît
forte mais il n'y a rien d'officiel
je pense que dans les jours qui viennent
les grandes choses les grandes choses sa
complice avec le temps sur votre allié
puisqu'on parlait des européennes ont
parlé du modem je voulais en venir un
petit peu aux municipales aussi puisque
c'est dans trois semaines
là est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression parfois que votre allié le
modem de françois bayrou par un petit
peu c'est parti dans tous les sens comme
il a pu le faire d'ailleurs dans le
passé en 2008
ces différentes avec l'ump a beau
évidemment françois bayrou mais aussi
mes pauses dans certaines villes avec le
parti socialiste
au fil des semaines enfin quel est le
parti qui n'a pas qui n'a pas de
problème de la préparation des
municipales dans toutes les formations
politiques politique autant éparpillé
des individualités qui transgresse les
directives du parti pour l'essentiel je
crois pouvoir dire que le modem après
les décisions d'exclusion à savon du
communiqué ont été publiés par exemple
par exemple par exemple les chemins se
sont auto exclu par communiqué avant que
françois bayrou si ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'ils avaient bien compris que le
modem été recadrée que lorsque françois
bayrou est candidat la maison fut aussi
tout par la maison modem
disons donc des clarifications s'est
opéré et lorsque françois bayrou s'est
engagé pour les municipales à pau il me
semble que les choses sont claires il a
le soutien d'alain juppé et j'ai entendu
un certain nombre de maires sortants de
grandes villes exprimé le souhait que le
modem dans son positionnement plutôt
centre-droit maintenant puissent venir
apporter son sont à point ou soutenir
sans condition à pau françois bayrou
oui naturellement enfin à partir du moi
je suis est ce que vous le voyez
françois bayrou ce qu'on voit plus à
paris obsédé par poux il est tout le
temps à pau se tenaient même pas dû
téléphoner c'est très bien ça veut dire
que s'investit complètement vous voyez
dans les réunions négociations la veille
absolument pas plus tard que la semaine
passée
d'accord absolument il vient asseoir
quelques réunions essentiel moi j'ai
besoin de confiance et je peux pas
passer mon temps à me méfier parce que
hier ou avant-hier il est temps de
regarder devant nous la situation est
suffisamment grave en france aujourd'hui
pour ne pas avoir des nostalgies pour
passer son temps dans le rétroviseur
nous avons à faire face à une révolution
perdre à une révolution
technologique permanente aux défis de la
mondialisation et on est là en train de
chipoter est aussi impatient élections
locales du mariage vous êtes aussi
volontaire et enthousiaste quatre mois
je le serai maman du lancement de
l'alternative
même si finalement l'alternative on
n'entend pas beaucoup on l'entend pas
beaucoup
téléspectateurs mettez moi dit du modem
de françois bayrou et 2 jean louis
borloo ça ne se fait pas ça ne devait
pas du jour au lendemain
chaque membre de nos formations
politiques à son histoire son vécu ses
ressentiments
mais essayons de sortir de ces de ses
jumeaux de circonstance pour
l'alternative
moi je suis je serai pas de politique je
n'étais pas optimiste
et donc je suis optimiste on information
d'abord parce que j'observe qu'elle se
rassemblent c'est vrai que ça prend du
temps mais c'est mieux
lorsque on a à sortir d'impasse et un
peu compliqué de crispation de
d'engueulades mutuelle de séparation et
que l'on découvre un jour que finalement
tout ceci n'a pas de sens et qu' il ya
un pays à sortir de l'ornière
la france est en train de se
marginaliser et on ne peut pas en rester
là
donc nos petites histoires de personnes
sanaa m ça n'a pas de sens il faut
mettre nos partis politiques au service
d'un projet pour l'expression d'une
vision et faire partager notre confiance
à nos concitoyens une petite question
sur jean louis borloo est ce que vous
avez de ces nouvelles qu'elle quel est
son état
je les ai eus hier jeudi hier au
téléphone il se remet et il nous permet
d'expérimenter notre capacité à
fonctionner en son absence c'est plutôt
bon signe quand une organisation quelle
qu'elle soit harry va permettre je veux
dissiper je veux dissiper contrainte
je comprends votre impatience mais vous
ne serez pas déçu à la sortie très
neutre
on a suivi cette déclaration solennelle
à l'ump après les révélations jeudi
dernier du point notamment ses
déclarations sur plus de transparence à
ce qui vous a convaincu hier jean
françois copé comment vous dire
je pense qu'il ya suffisamment de loi
pour pour assurer cette cette
transparence des progrès considérables
ont été accomplis donc le recours à de
nouvelles lois
comme on a du mal à lui a donné l'image
delà de la puissance effective de la de
l'effectivité de l'action alors il est
tentant de prendre la loi pour
communiquer moi je pense que ce qu'ils
font je pense je pense que c'est parce
harris trop souvent tout du gouvernement
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est que les
lois actuelles s'applique et dans les
relations contractuelles que peuvent
avoir les partis ou les hommes
politiques de veiller à respecter une
une déontologie pour ne pas faire naître
le soupçon du fait de proximité de
connivence et de je ne sais quelle
complaisance et lorsque il y à une
suspicion possible il faut mieux
l'éviter
et si on ne peut pas l'éviter pour des
raisons compréhensibles il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont et met les
informations sur la table il n'a pas été
assez précautionneux dans l'emploi de
ses amis entrait pas de jugement je m'en
tiens à ce que je viens de dire
d'accord mais c'est votre allié naturel
c'est écrit dans la charte
de l'alternative s'est ralliée naturel
et bien j'y parle pour les municipales
mon allié de françois bayrou à pau jean
françois copé s'est il ya comme il ya
comme une ambiguïté mais via des hauts
et des bas oui mais enfin alain juppé
qui est quand même donné une autorité au
sein de la grande famille ump a pris
clairement position pour françois bayrou
quand même fois en meeting samedi soir à
pau a nagé plaît bien alors n'est ce pas
l'image d'une sorte d'alliance et de
compréhension mutuelle
une vraie solidarité merci on va
maintenant parler jean arthuis avant
d'accueillir un mécano ahmed public
sénat sur le plateau d'une proposition
de loi que vous avez déposé au sénat qui
demande à l'état de prendre en charge
financièrement les mineurs étrangers
isolés car depuis une circulaire de 2013
et bien ces mineurs qui arrivent en
france essentiellement dans des
départements de la petite couronne
parisienne sont répartis maintenant dans
tous les départements français mais pour
bien comprendre le sujet je propose
d'abord avant d'en parler en plateau de
regarder le reportage en sainte famille
de sonia béchir ils viennent
essentiellement d'afrique subsaharienne
mais aussi d'inde ou du bangladesh à
paris la permanence d'accueil et
d'orientation des mineurs isolés
étrangers voient défiler 1300 jeunes
sans famille chaque année une fois leur
situation évaluer ils sont orientés vers
les structures dette sociale à l'enfance
l'essentiel de notre activité porte sur
pouvoir permettre à ces jeunes de
bénéficier d'informations
une formation qui est essentiellement
professionnalisantes pour nous parler
voie de l'apprentissage les mêmes dans
les centres de formation pour apprentis
donc leur trouver un employeur
en france l'aide sociale à l'enfance
relève des départements problème la
plupart des mineurs isolés étrangers
arrivent en ile-de-france pour
désengorger les services de ces zones
surchargé une circulaire a mis en place
en 2013 un mécanisme de solidarité
nationale de la circulaire de pouvoir
permettre à paris notamment et la
seine-saint-denis de pouvoir accueillir
peut-être moins mineurs isolés en la
répartition sur l'ensemble territoire
pour une meilleure qualité de prise en
charge était vraiment l'essentiel bon
nombre de départements ain finalement
l'essentiel ont participé
à cette solidarité nationale et ont
accueilli les mineurs en question
seulement certains départements dénonce
une explosion de leur dépenses d'aidé à
l'enfance
une proposition de loi initiée par le
sénateur jean arthuis demande la prise
en charge intégrale de ces mineurs par
l'état un texte mal reçue en seine saint
denis qui accueille chaque année 800
jeunes souhaitent une dépense de 45
millions d'euros
si la proposition de monsieur arthuis
s'est finalement de se contenter de dire
écoutez il arrive à un endroit il faut
qu'ils soient prises en charge dans cet
endroit géographique et on verra pour la
prise en charge financière pour que ça
soit mieux assumée par l'état
ça ce n'est pas acceptable au delà de la
répartition géographique
ici on s'inquiète surtout de la
proposition de créer des centres
spécifiques pour les mineurs isolés
étrangers qui sont aujourd'hui prises en
charge aux côtés de jeunes français
notamment sur ces sujets à jean arthuis
pour la question tout simplement est ce
que vous considérez séminaire désolé
tout d'abord comme des étrangers ou des
mineurs ce sont des mineurs étrangers
le problème est que nombre d'entre eux
ne sont pas des mineurs ils viennent
soit avec des faux papiers soient sans
papiers maintenant il souffre des
mineurs les vrais mineurs c'est qu'ils
ont sous 18 ans n'est pas tout casser
chassons cette façon lorsque ce que je
veux dire c'est que des filières se sont
mises en place pour faciliter une
immigration clandestine ayant recours à
notre législation qui protège l'enfance
et les familles et donc lorsqu'un mineur
supposé mineurs étrangers se présente
dans un département
les autorités judiciaires le procureur
le juge aux enfants le place dans un
bruit à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
avaient attendu tard david tout à
l'heure et 10 n ya pas que des filières
il ya aussi des jeunes qui viennent ici
tout simplement procès trouver du
travail ou qui rejoignent ou qui peuvent
rejoindre des familles que je veux dire
ce sont des phénomènes d'immigration
je ne demande pas je veux pas faire une
opération financière moi ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que c'est un phénomène
qui est en train de se développer
considérablement
il y avait tant mayenne humide
isolé et manger 8,8 en 2008 et nous
étions à 64,65 au mois de juillet 2013
kim qui met en péril le bon
fonctionnement nos propres foyers et de
l'action éducative de nos collaborateurs
sociaux il s'agit de phénomènes
d'immigration c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demande au gouvernement que
ce soit l'état dans des pôles régionaux
ou suprarégionaux d'accueillir ces
jeunes pour évaluer l'orage d'abord pour
vérifier leur identité
l'aspect financier j'ai dit très
clairement que leurs yeux débat que ce
qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui à mon
département
je suis prêt à le rendre à l'état dès
lors que c'est lui qui se charge de
l'accueil de séminaires le débat va
revenir au sénat est-ce que vous pensez
que ça pourrait être votée ou pas j'ai
goûté
j'espère en tout cas ce que je crois
c'est que chacun aujourd'hui reconnaît
que c'est un vrai problème
le gouvernement lorsque madame taubira
avait mis au point cette circulaire et 6
mai qui avait à peu près 1500 arrivée de
mineurs par an
lors du débat il y à un mois au sénat
madame taubira nous a dit que c'était un
peu plus de 4000 et personne ne le sait
parce qu'il n'y a pas de statistiques
c'est un des phénomènes d'immigration
non contrôlée je demande à l'état
d'assumer cette responsabilité et au
delà de l'état à l'europe puisque c'est
l'espace schengen à moi j'avais un petit
peu votre avenir par l'espace schengen a
parlé de l'europe
vous êtes à priori candidats on va voir
ça dans quelques jours vous l'avez dit
on n'y va pas pour occuper des postes
vous avez dit tout à l'heure un débours
à claude mais vous n'étiez pas bien au
sénat écoutez j'ai été très heureux au
sénat c'est une maison d'amour bouger
fantastique mais parce que dans la vie
on peut pas toujours faire la même chose
à écouter j'étais lui je me suis échappé
deux fois pour aller au gouvernement son
histoire mais le constat que je fais
aujourd'hui et surtout depuis 2011
c'est que il ya une majorité de gauche
au sénat mais il n'y a pas de majorité
pour soutenir le gouvernement donc les
grands textes les budgets les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale la
réforme des retraites
repartant copie blanche à l'assemblée
nationale on voudrait
montrer la valeur ajoutée des élections
sénateur a ajouté cette halte à gaza
peut changer les choses je veux dire ma
conviction aujourd'hui c'est que sur des
questions essentielles politique
monétaire régulation financière comment
tenir les marchés financiers contrôler
les opérateurs les banques l'europe
prévenir les risques tous décident de
tout se décide au niveau européen puis
rien précisément puis en france donc le
pouvoir détenu en france il ya encore du
pouvoir en france mais je dis que sur un
certain nombre de grandes missions
régaliennes lutte contre la fraude
fiscale contre les paradis fiscaux
politique énergétique politique de
défense diplomatie aide aux pays en voie
de développement
si la prérogative est exercée au plan
national s'est très vite le constat de
l'impuissance politique
sommes nous à ce point résigné donc je
pense que sur ces questions
fondamentales
c'est au plan européen qu'on doit
pouvoir avancer j'ai vu comment on n'a
pas gouverner la zone euro
et j'en suis scandalisé j'en veux à nos
chefs d'état et de gouvernement l'europe
est devenue l'espèce de kaléidoscope ça
donne
vous êtes en train de nous dire que la
nôtre en sueur et les gouvernements
français se soient de droite comme de
gauche on est impuissant dans ta
circoncis marine le pen ou non il faut
pas rester là et croyez vous que c'est
en reprenant à supprimer l'euro par
exemple
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure mais
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
supprimait l'euro toutes nos dettes sont
le rouge et on retrouverait d'autres
monnaies nationales toutes nos dettes
chanteur d'euros notre modèle national
que deviendrait-elle ya les pays comme
l'allemagne dont la monnaie s'apprécie
ray donc pour eux pas de problème tout
fonctionne oui mais il ya des pays comme
la france qui retrouveraient leurs
monnaies nationales qui se déprécierait
par rapport à l'euro aujourd'hui nous
importons 60 milliards d'euros d'énergie
fossile demain si nous revenons à notre
monnaie nationale nous subirons une
inflation énorme sur ses importations
d'énergie fossile ça veut dire que quand
vous ferez le plein de carburant dans
votre voiture vous le paierez 20 à 30 ou
40 % plus cher
vous vous demanderez aussi comment vous
ferez face à votre facture de chauffage
dans votre appartement
j'ai envie de vous poser la question
vous avez le temps dira si la
suppression active et la suppression de
l'euro celle apocalypse now
vous avez le temps d'y réfléchir vous me
répondrez peut-être à la fin de
l'émission
pire souvenir meilleur souvenir au sénat
vous savez déjà ou pas vous laisser plus
d'un petit peu le temps d'affichage est
notre question du point souvenirs à la
commission des finances jean nous avons
fait nous allons faire que de belles
choses malheureusement on n'a pas dû
parler assez fort sur ces questions mon
grand souvenir
c'est la mission que j'ai avait conduite
en 1993 on rapport sur les
délocalisations et la mondialisation
je me suis fait enguirlander par tout le
monde j'annonçais ce qui allait se
passer dans l'automobile les pertes
d'emplois qui allait venir et ses
contradictions qu'il y avait c'est
formidable de dire je défends les
consommateurs mais quand on défend les
consommateurs tout en maintenant nos
lois sociales que dis-je en augmentant
les standards sociaux les charges
sociales et en demandant à ceux qui
produisent encore en france de faire
face à cela mais c'est absurde à venir
c'est lequel le pire souvenir au goût
des jeux j'ai de très bons souvenirs
j'ai des bons souvenirs estimé qu
institution sénat et bien défendu
aujourd'hui non pourquoi parce que il
n'ya pas de gouvernance au sonore donc
c'est que j'aurais dis je les dis au
président à plusieurs reprises je lui
écris l'été dernier il avait présenté
son rapport sur le bilan de l'action du
sénat pendant l'année 2012 2013 et il
exprimait une satisfaction
très apparentes je lui ai écrit
instantanément pour lire je ne
partageais pas son point de vue que le
sénat devrait être le lieu où les
clivages politiques s'estompe où on
recherche un consensus sur les questions
liées à l'école l'éducation la
compétitivité comment comment recréer de
l'emploi dans ce pays
comment faire avancer les grandes idées
sociétale et ne pas jouer le clone de
l'assemblée nationale et se soumettre au
fait majoritaire ça n'a pas de sens
pétange auras-tu j'ai deux petites
questions
vous avez été ministre de l'économie ce
que vous estimez qu'il ya un chef à
bercy en ce moment coutu je penserais
pas de jugement je trouve que ce
gouvernement n'a pas pris la mesure de
la situation c'est si vrai que pendant
deux ans il a conduit d'une politique
qui vient de contredire
je parlais veux qu'ils étaient comme l'a
dit jean louis borloo les aveux du
président hollande ils sont rendus
compte que tout ce qu'ils avaient fait
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
allait à l'encontre de l'intérêt du pays
alors maintenant on invente un très beau
concept de pacte de responsabilité si un
remaniement ce qu'il faut un
gouvernement resserré sans doute que la
commission nissan sortir estimé
moi je pense qu'une vingtaine de
ministres ça suffit et c'est possible ça
aujourd'hui penser que l'actuelle
majorité peut le faire écouter ça c'est
pas vraiment ça s'est passé pas mon
problème je voudrais d'abord que devenir
que l'opposition que l'opposition se se
tient d'autrement parce que c'est ces
espèces de va-et-vient ces jeux stériles
dès que dès qu'un homme politique shore
avec des idées un peu courageuse il se
fait canarder par son camp et par tout
le monde
or on voit bien que la voie est étroite
et donc il faut que nous puissions
rassembler très largement pour aller de
l'avant et redonner confiance à nos
concitoyens
l on va finir par une petite anecdote
votre réaction à ce sondage du parisien
magazine qui n'a pas été publié le
week-end dernier cas il placé dominique
strauss kahn en tête des personnalités
politiques que les français
aurait aimé et qui aurait pu mieux faire
que françois hollande s'en inspire quoi
écouter mieux faire que françois
hollande arrive en tête c'est pas
l'exercice le plus difficile mais sans
doute meeting de gauche comme de droite
ah bon on de droite aussi et du centre
sûrement sûrement suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr parce que dans les sondages il
ya une espèce de sélection la convention
on extrait ça surprend la
théâtralisation de la politique non je
pense qu'au plan économique domine
strauss kahn a de bonnes idées
malheureusement il est quand même le
concepteur des 35 heures en 1997 et on
voit les conséquences des 35 heures sur
la compétitivité de l'économie française
et niveau du chômage
donc je pense que certains politiques
auraient intérêt à faire preuve d'un peu
d'humilité
merci beaucoup michael szames assez
merci jean arthuis d'avoir été notre
invité ce soir dans preuve par toi merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi la semaine
prochaine c'est emmanuelle cosse la
patronne d'europe écologie les verts qui
sera notre invité très bonne soirée à
tous sur un thème de public sénat